we were just told literally in the last
minute that Tucker Carlson is leaving
Fox News Now Dan bongino left Fox News
last week now Tucker apparently is
leaving do we have any more info I guess
we'll we'll get some more info uh but
it's a it's a I mean this is game there
we go Tucker Carlson out at Fox News it
seems difficult to believe but Tucker
Carlson is no longer with Fox News the
announcement was confirmed by the
network this morning I mean this is
massive massive you got to understand
guys Tucker Carlson
is the number one rated host in the
history of cable news the absolute
history of cable news I have no idea
where Tucker's going I have no idea but
I do know that when Tucker walked into
my house years ago for the first time he
said and I quote I'm gonna I'm gonna
drop an F-bomb for a second he walks
into my garage sees my whole home
operation and he goes holy
you're living the dream that's what
Tucker said so is he about to go
independent I have no idea but this is
this is absolutely huge obviously we'll
have more on that soon is this related
to the to the lawsuit and you know
everything else with dominion and all
that I I don't know but actually it's a
perfect moment because I was about to
segue to Tucker because Tucker I think
has been showing us in some ways how to
win by fighting the culture War
appropriately calling out the nonsense
not apologizing
etc etc uh and here's a video that we
just found of Tucker talking about how
you go ahead and Lead within 10
integrity and fight when you should
fight
ing was super obvious like those of us
who were in our mid-50s are caught in
the past in the way that we think about
you know I've got this idea
and we've got this idea let's have a
debate about our ideas they don't want a
debate
those ideas won't produce outcomes that
any rational person would want under any
circumstances
those are manifestations of some larger
force acting upon us
it's just so obvious
it's completely obvious
and I think two things one
we should say that
and stop engaging in these totally
fraudulent debates
where we are using the terms that we
used in 1991 when I started at Heritage
as if maybe you know I could just win
the debate if I marshaled more facts
I've tried that doesn't work
and two maybe we should all take just
like 10 minutes a day to say a prayer
about it
I'm serious like why not
all right so there's a bit of a winning
model I think it's something that I've
been trying to model here to some degree
too right you can't just say the right
thing all the time and hope that that
will proliferate around right if you're
always losing the culture of War right I
think this is something that
conservatives and again when I say
conservatives I mean this broad
Coalition of people just decent people
who believe in reality I think one of
the things that we've done that should
be the tagline I should it's our new
party decent people who believe in
reality the most controversial racist
party in the history of the world
you can't just do it that way you can't
because they will just keep coming you
will you will lay out facts and they
will ignore those facts they will live
in their reality they won't accept basic
biology all those things so what he's
saying is you have to have sort of a
holistic approach when it comes to going
back on offense yeah you have to have
facts and you have to have reality and I
think you know often at the end there
when he says talk about praying it's
like that there's a spiritual component
of this there is something that's within
you that will make you stand up straight
with your shoulders back that then will
allow you to approach properly
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]